hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
we're going to look at leak code 202
happy number so what makes a number
happy
they explain it to us in the problem
statement
so we're given an input number n and we
want to know
is it happy or not if it's happy we can
return true
and we're done if it's not happy we're
going to return
false but how do you determine if it's a
happy number or not
in this example they gave us a nineteen
so let's work with that so all we need
to do is take
each digit so the first digit one
square it the second digit nine
square it add them together
and then compute the sum
but we're not done yet to determine if
it's actually happy or not
we're going to take this number now and
do the same thing
and we're going to keep repeating this
process right so we would take 8 squared
plus 2 squared and then we get 68
and we're going to keep going now if the
number reaches
a 1 just like it did in this example so
eventually
we're going to go to 68 we're going to
go to 100
and then we're going to get to 1.
and if it reaches a 1 like this then
it's a happy number if it doesn't ever
reach a one
then it's not a happy number and we're
going to return false
but they also tell us that no matter
what whether it's a happy number or not
it's going to loop endlessly so notice
how this
one if you take one and square it
one squared is equal to one one squared
is equal to one so
when we keep doing this we're going to
get stuck in an infinite loop
but even if we never reach a 1 we'll
still be stuck in an infinite loop
so you guys know how much i like to
visualize problems so let's
do exactly that so we start with a 19.
then we get to eighty-two
then we get to sixty-eight
then we get to a hundred
and then we get to the number that
proves to us
that 19 is happy
now we get to a one right and now this
one
is going to loop infinitely and
therefore we know
that 1 or 19 is a happy
number but let's take a look at a
different example
what if our input was equal to
2 instead of 19.
then what's going to happen so we first
start with a 2
we can square the 2 and we get to 4.
we can square the 4 and we get to
16. now this is the part where you're
gonna have to trust my math
so if we take the sum of squares
of digits of 16 we're gonna get to
37 if we take the sum of squares of 37
which is
9 and 21 we get 230.
next 3 squared plus 0 squared that's
a 9. 9 squared is eighty-one
eighty-one squared is
sixty-five
sixty-five squared is sixty-one
or the sum of squares of 65 is 61.
and now 6 squared
plus 1 squared is
37 and you notice anything
about this there's a 37 right
over here so basically
the exact same thing happened right we
started at 2
we did some stuff and then we got stuck
in an infinite loop right it's just
going to keep going around and round and
round
infinitely right so what does this tell
us well in this case
the input number 2 is not happy
so instead of returning true we're going
to return false
so basically what we're trying to do is
check
if we ever get to basically
do we ever visit a number twice and how
can we do that efficiently well you
might have heard there's a data
structure called
a hash set that we can use and i'm going
to show you how to code that up right
now
so i'm doing this in python so let's
create
a visit hash set to keep track of
every number that we previously visited
so that if we get to a number that we
visit twice we can
instantly know in constant speed right
hash sets are really quick
and now we just want to compute the sum
of squares of
n until n is
repeated until we get a duplicate value
so i'm gonna go until
n is not in visit so if n hasn't
been visited so if n hasn't been visited
then the first thing we can do
is add it to our visit
and the next thing we want to do is
compute the
sum of squares
so i'm not going to do that here i'm
going to separate that out into a helper
function
like i'm doing right now so we're going
to pass n into this function
we're going to compute the sum of
squares and we're going to reassign n
to that value so before i forget let me
actually define this helper function
and so what's going to be the condition
that we return true
so remember the single number that we're
looking for is 1.
if n ever equals 1 we're done
like we can just return true
and we could have even put this part
like at the beginning of our code if we
wanted to if the input value was one
just instantly return one we don't even
need to do anything
but in the case that we visit a value
twice like if our loop stops executing
that means we visited about we visited a
value twice
but in the case that we visited a value
twice
and that value was not one then
we need to return false because we know
our
loop is going to stop executing and we
know that we didn't reach a value that
was
1 so we can just return false
now for the annoying part we actually
gotta compute these sum of squares of
digits
so let me just explain what i'm gonna do
before i actually write the code for
that
so we're talking about taking 19 right
getting the sum of squares
and then adding them up but how do we
actually do that in code it's a little
bit annoying but once you
kind of figure it out it's not too bad
so if you take
19 mod it
by 10
you get the ones place value right
so we want to take this 9 because we
need it to compute the sum of squares
so when you do this you get a value 9.
so now that we have our 9 we don't
actually need this
anymore so what are we going to do i'm
going to take 19
and divide it by 10. now we know in
code this is not going to do what you'd
expect in math right this is not going
to be a fraction
we want to just get rid of this 9. so in
code this is going to this is going to
equal
1 right so that's great now we got our
one
and we have our nine so now we just can
take the squares of them
and add them together so this is kind of
the process that i'm gonna do except
we're gonna do it in code and we're
gonna use a loop
oh and one more thing so notice how we
have our one now
if we mod it by 10
we're gonna get zero right and zero
squared is of course
zero when we take our one and divide it
by 10
we're also going to get zero so that's
how you know we're finished right so
this isn't going to loop forever
okay so now we can finish this helper
function and then finally be done with
our solution
so i'm going to declare a variable for
the output which is going to be the sum
of squares value
initially it's going to be 0.
so while n is not 0
and we can just say while n in python at
least
we're going to continue our loop we're
going to continue taking each digit
and squaring it and adding it to our
output
so remember how do we get that digit we
can take
n mod it by 10
and we also have to square our digit so
we can in python at least say digit
double star two so that's squaring in
python
and we can take our output and add this
digit
and the last thing we have to do is
remember update our value
n because we're done with this digit but
now we have to find the next digit
and so in python at least these two mean
integer division in java in most
languages you can just get away with one
and so this loop is going to keep going
until n is equal to zero
and then we can finally return that
output
and our solution works it's not the most
efficient solution
i'll tell you that so we needed a set
right
the set made it so our memory complexity
was big o of n there's a
actually slightly better way to do this
and the better way to do this
is just like this suggested problem a
lengthless cycle
because if you remember the drawings i
was showing
this problem is a linked list problem at
its heart right so if you solve linked
list cycle
you're pretty much solving this problem
as well but thank you so much for
watching if this was helpful
like and subscribe and i hope to see you
soon